If you blink, you die. That’s the first
thing you need to know about SCP-173,
a monstrous living sculpture
contained by the SCP Foundation,
a Secret organization dedicated to
protecting humanity from the anomalous.
Also known as The Sculpture, The Killer
Statue, and even sometimes… The Peanut,
this unassuming piece of modern art remains
completely still while you’re looking at it.
However, if you look away, even
for a fraction of a second,
the statue will dart towards you at lightning
speeds. What happens if it reaches you?
Simply put, the sculpture will snap your
neck with a nasty crunch - its favorite
way to dispatch a victim. There’s no
way to fight back against SCP-173.
All you can do is keep looking and hope you
don’t blink, that’s the only way to survive.
Of course the average human blinks
about twelve times per minute. So now
ask yourself, how many times have
you blinked while watching this?